hi welcome to people playground it's not
what you think
but somehow it's probably going to be
worse um this is a game that's a lot
like
interactive buddy which is sad to
mention because flash has now been
officially discontinued that doesn't
mean that you can't still play some of
those games but flash
is kind of being purged from the
internet so a lot of the old flash games
are kind of
going by the wayside but some of them
are coming to steam in bundles and the
developers are actually kind of
getting paid which is good i don't know
why i'm getting all moby about it she
said i mean
bring the mood down i'm here to kill
people anyway
abyss what the hell what that
okay so people playground is a lot like
that
okay e or q to spawn selected object
left mouse to drag
why are things just horror games
came here to destroy
what is this supposed to be i came here
to have a good time
box select us press right mouse and
select delete okay
delete oh there was one more box that i
didn't read i did not think that through
okay e
hey how you doing pal good to see you
you really want to stand up straight
don't you about another person
you're taller how [ __ ] dare you
gorse relatively small awful creature
courses are intelligent and malicious
they also tend to smell of burnt glue
well let me just spawn it in the pit
oh you okay
oh
[Music]
oh i'm not a murderer
you're all right oh i think they're
probably fine
hello oh no
oh what the hell happened
oh no
hello okay well the course
what is that the course seems most
certainly
dead i regret
everything okay so there's a dude over
there
android over here maybe
hi wow look at that well of course can't
hurt you
yeah can't even bother it
what are you gonna do no okay uh
oh uh oh oh hang on
oh boy i'll let them work out their
aggression
okay hey dude at least you're not dead
man i'm so glad you're here
i'm worm staff no
no wait i can slam this against androids
to repair them perfect
how you doing over here buddy fine it's
fine
clank clank clink clink clank clink
clink clink clink you're fine buddy
you're fine
all right he's good she it they're good
this
i don't like the implications of that
look this guy this original guy is my
buddy
i'm not gonna get a little close to that
buddy
just take a put your right foot in you
take your right foot out
that's too much blood that's so much
blood
that is so much blood that is
still too much blood why is there
so much blood goodbye this is an
impossible amount of blood this can't be
this is impossible put them in the pit
put them in the pit in the pit
and there you go goodbye stand up for
yourself buddy
end up for yourself stand up for
yourself
okay all right you keep it up man you
keep it up you keep up there good work
all right man this is uh that's really
something why did that do so much
what does it do to an android hello
worms
yeah they can't do nothing okay it's
going to be the pit of worms
go in the bit okay here we go here we go
buddy don't worry about thing don't
worry about things don't worry about
things
so much blood it's just an impossible
amount of blood
it's so much it should not be no
get out of there are you okay you okay
you okay can i get you a med kit is
there a med kit there a medkit on this
med kit you're okay you're okay bud
listen if you die i will never forgive
myself
i will probably forgive myself
electricity transformer
activation transformer fire detector
life detector decimator
decimator oh what is it what is all of
this
ah what is factorio up in here
thruster bed thruster man
oh uh oh uh um oh uh oh
ah okay you're going in the pit sorry
you're in horrible pain just
yeah you go here there you go enjoy
defibrillator bring him back into this
hell
claire are you alive yeah they seem good
standing up on your own there buddy
standing up there we go that's on the
heart that's on the heart
there we go claire
okay well it doesn't put it in the pit
in the pit in the bit in the pit in the
bit oh you forgot this
okay hey bud how are you doing good to
see you ah don't worry about a thing
ooh acid syringe adrenaline shot bone
eating syringe
that seems bad coagulation will heal all
bleeding wounds
death syringe freeze syringe knockout
syringe life
ooh in the head
in the head okay
what was that well i'd give them ultra
strength the zoinkas
zoinkas how is this not working
i feel like this should be working right
whoa did i get you
you good oh
okay ah right in the ass okay
okay uh in the butt
oh so this guy's good let's test out
this immortality theory here we go right
in the
leg well that doesn't seem to be
immortal
well he's not dead oh
that's straight blown out ass oh that's
blown out ass no no no no
no nope hang on in the ass
there we go yeah there's get your ass
blown back in there you go
okay well that's that that you're not
immortal heel heel heel heel heel heel
heel heel
yeah okay well why aren't you immortal
then this is bizarre
okay makes living beings more durable i
guess
getting shot a couple times ain't happy
well don't slip on my gun
hold still hold
okay what are you
so bouncy what
stop what is this you wanna be stabbed
in the gooch
all right we're gonna leave this in you
okay
oh my god what's wrong with you
well stop it what's wrong with you don't
you're gonna go in the pit
careful no no no no slow motion okay
and grouchy gotcha i gotcha i gotcha i i
got you
i got you i got you i got you i almost
had you there
almost had you and i got you and i got
you i've got you
i got you i have you there nope so close
i
have you no have you nope i've got you
got you i have got you i've
got you i have you i've got you oh boy
i've
got you i got yeah i go i
got him yeah
yeah yeah
oh my god are you okay
you okay you okay
oh he's back up and he's bouncing again
all right you
stop stop stop
in the dick you just leave that in you
okay you leave that right in you all
right
detached what oh what the frick
you okay buddy oh god okay uh hang on
slow
okay slow slow slow i got you
that was a close one pal that was really
close hang on
you all right now you're still kicking
literally still kicking
literally still kicking whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
yo yo yo yo whoa whoa
and this shot's really something huh
you like that you like the juice well
this is
definitely different than i thought it
was going to be you still
almost pushed them i forgot you were
here
um you're good you just you you keep
that up you keep doing that
does this do oh well that looks powerful
oh my god oh my god okay wait wait wait
wait wait so you have this good go
321 baby
i have you clear
there we go all better now oh
god you're up you're up pal man you're
up
enough of giving this guy the business i
want to start creating here let's uh
let's make a wall
let's make a little pen okay that's uh i
wonder if we can
box it in a little bit you know create
some okay i'm
so strong
why fine this is the pen i guess so i
want to
do something else this guy i'm going to
carry a couple people here i don't
really care about them i want to do this
zombie syringe thing
hmm seems to be going a little gray
there
you okay belle well they seem okay all
right well i guess i can create more
walls then
oh i guess i could freeze him right
freeze right
you uh you okay did he not go all the
way or something
okay that's not what i meant
i think they're getting better huh i
guess you don't do nothing after all
very strange not exactly what i was
expecting um
all right you okay
are you okay you okay
oh they're alive how are you alive
how are you oh sorry bud you're at oh
what
oh oh this is weird
heel oh they're fine and you're fine
and you're fine oh they're just
reinfecting again
no you're fine you're fine you're fun
very strange i thought it would have
been a little different thing let me try
this
well okay i think this is the zombie one
damn well these zombies are kind of lame
they don't seem to be doing anything
oh well whatever it's not a big deal
oh my god
all right buddy oh shoot wait which
one's buddy
you my buddy this is buddy buddy i know
my buddy anywhere
that's my buddy right you need the heel
gun the reconstructor
[Music]
well buddy buddy stop stop your hell's
not over yet i swear
yeah he's definitely my buddy and you're
good
i think i can bring this guy back
all right man this is good stuff let's
clear
debris number one rain
oh that's kind of depressing
snow now that's lovely
five blood tank
what oh
thunder snow perfect let's clear
everything okay
i said goodbye to my buddy but you know
it's about time to go there powers
pull lift lightning
oh cool oh my god
that is sick oh that's sick
oh my god
okay guys i i've literally spent so long
doing absolutely nothing i get that
point of this
is to basically
[Applause]
how about you
oh my god that thing's still alive man
that android is durable
zam zoom whoa fire
boom well um
okay so what i'm gonna do put some
people down here
oh oh well that's a problem
oom bam whoops
whoa my god okay
fire well uh that was a bit too many
yeah they're just [ __ ] bombs
all right all right now it's time to
break the game
starting to get a little laggy
all right here we go
oh my god
[Music]
all right well that's a little something
all right let's get a different map here
let's try blocks
ah well then can i give oh
this is that way bigger than i thought
it would can i
give someone a gun you want this
take it i don't think that there's a way
to get them to
try to kill each other the thing about
this is i don't know too much about this
game but the good news is there's a lot
of people out there that already do and
they've made things in the workshop so i
want to
now that i've had a little taste for
destruction i want to see what other
people are making
human tears okay cool human tears
hazmat mod remastered and expanded oh
interesting all right skittle syringe
mod
blood thinner ghost syringe boom syringe
yeah i'm getting that one all right
that'll be good enough for now i don't
want to get too many or else i'm going
to just
end up blowing up the entire game this
is fun it's it's like catharth
to them right it's cathartism it's
cathartic
okay mods uh let's activate activate
activate okay this should
probably be fine hello oh hazmat alien
neat highly improved human okay
can absorb other humans to become
stronger
acid human disintegrates flesh on touch
crusher rip and tear enemy of humanity
has immunity to most other powers can
absorb people with powers to gain their
powers
right click on the hand to change
current ability fancy course
and then giant human giant even oh oh
you how regular human oh well that's not
that giant
i was thinking that was much more giant
than it was
do they not fight each other or
something is there a way to make them
fight each other
you all right there buddy you okay but
you okay buddy there must be a way to
make them because it says
that they can do things so it's got to
be a way to make them do things right
touch touch
touch you touch touch touch
touch i'm touching your nose
touch
whoa uh didn't know i could do that oh
too big oh they fell apart
okay uh crusher embigonate
wham there we go now that's what i'm
talking about
swam all right this should work right
oh my god
no what happened to you
like uh hang on i gotta look this up or
something oh there's a mod
okay active humans most subscribed
active humans
nice okay so human big
good human
they don't seem very active oh
where are you going where where are you
where are you go
no that's not what i meant by where are
you going
where are you going where are you going
okay um
fight i guess no running away oh
bye
you okay oh he's okay oh god
okay i'm just going to play in this
corner here a giant am in here
this guy
all right go for it
this is not exactly what i was thinking
it was gonna be boom syringe
well hang on giant kaboom
you know i feel like i just shouldn't
have
any kind of powers
oh hi bud
what what hang on
hold on i'll be with you in a moment sir
what it's a torso
okay this is [ __ ]
oh my god
what
what
what is that
oh you know the whole thing about nukes
or
equivalent tnt right now let's get a
volunteer
uh you there you go bud
well that was pretty violent what
happens when i drop a nuke down this
will it
explode when it gets to the bottom
probably won't oh that guy's still down
there
oh alright bud
okay who
what what what what is that
hang on are you
have you ascended beyond where that new
go i need to blow it up uh
sorry bud you gotta you gotta go
wow i did you did i get him
i probably got him how many nukes can i
set off down
boom
oh they don't all go off
ah that's a shame okay oh are you
hello oh my god uh do you need a fire
extinguisher
i can get that for you
oh you're still alive i'm something to
play with
okay
yeehaw so that is
people playground this game on steam is
very highly rated i mean obviously
there's just tons of stuff to do but
it's
it's a playground it's a sandbox you
make it what you will but at least
there's tons of mods to play around with
i bet there's tons of crazy things that
you could do with all those weird
like electronic things i don't even know
how but you could set up some pretty
elaborate stuff there
and also get a blood tank for some
reason and
i'm not 100 sure why so thank you
everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed this if you want to
play it it's obviously in the
description below hey like if you lost a
little bit of sanity today
subscribe if you think you're put on
several lists
and uh yeah let me know what you thought
down in the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you